رئيس همليل هانجابي يسأل عن رأس الوزير الميت
الثقة بمغادرة الغرفة وعدم البقاء في المناقشة
جالانت ليس مستعدًا لهذا ويقول أنا كذلك
يصنع ويأخذ معه أيضًا رئيس طاقمه
وكذلك السكرتير العسكري ويصفعه على رأسه
ستتوقف الحكومة ورئيس الدولة السابق عن إزعاجي
العمل مرة أخرى يعلمنا عن التوترات
المهم بين رئيس الوزراء ووزير الدفاع
التوترات التي بدأت قبل وقت طويل من أكتوبر ولكن
جرس
في هذه الأيام، ربما أكثر من أي وقت مضى أمس، لا يوجد حدث
ممتعة جدًا في خزانة الحرب ليست المرة الأولى
ونحن نعلم أن هناك صعودا وهبوطا بينهما
نتنياهو لبن جالانت في مرحلة ما قبل أن نقف فيها
أيام للحرب، المقصورة الحربية، مجلس الوزراء الخاص
وهذا رصيد لشعب إسرائيل، وهو في قلبي حقًا، أيها السادة
سيحاول البالغون الذين يديرون الملح التغلب على المشاكل
الشخصية سليمة ومن أجل شعب إسرائيل ومن أجل النصر
للحفاظ على هذه الخزانة لا أتذكر مثل هذا الحدث
وزير الدفاع في مجلس الوزراء الحربي أثناء الحرب
لقد أسقطت المناقشة، ولم يكن الأمر كذلك عندما أنظر إليها
المناقشات في مجلس الوزراء للسياسة الأمنية، كل ما يحدث
هذا الاسم ببساطة يبث الحروب
اليهود الوحيدون الذين يستفيدون هم الأوغاد
السنوار هيك، أنت لا تريد الحرب، لا تدعها تحدث
فرصة أخرى لإيذائنا بسبب د
الوحدة هي كل أولئك الذين يسلكون طريق الانقسام وقادتهم
الأشخاص المؤثرون والمسؤولون المنتخبون ينهارون
مبدأ التيارات يخلق الظروف لتهديد أمني
ووجود يارون أبراهام يحدثنا عن جدل
في القمة السياسية حول مسألة كيفية إعادتهم ماذا
الأسعار التي ترغب إسرائيل في دفعها صحيحة والجدل
هذا وفي قمة الاهتمامات السياسية الأيونية التوتر القائم بين
استمرار القتال حيث خطف الخنصر الهدفين
أن إسرائيل الرسمية حددت كديروت بإخضاع واحد
كأهداف موازية خلال الأشهر الثلاثة
هذا الأخير بعد ماري قليلا